could I have the egg white veggie
omelette bites I'll get the wake up wrap
sandwich egg please we can do that for
you the toasted almond cold brew oat
milk please it's gonna be 15 41. thank
you okay so I totally asked for a small
but our friend gave me the largest
coffee I've ever seen definitely not
gonna be able to finish this all
otherwise I'm gonna be bouncing off the
effing walls but let me show you what I
got got a little cold brew with some
sweet foam on top so good I got a egg
and cheese wake up wrap and I've got
these mini veggie egg bites here this
meal here is 24 grams of protein and
it's super satisfying for an on-the-go
breakfast
hmm